your income doesn't matter your age
doesn't matter your race doesn't matter
your geographical location doesn't
matter
there's a thing that you and I are
dealing with in your money and it's
called math and none of those things I
just mentioned give you a pass on math
and where people get themselves in
trouble including one I want broke many
years ago because I was stupid we get
ourselves in trouble when we don't
bother and do the math before we do the
transaction we're the stupid woman from
San Diego who leased her dog for fifty
four hundred dollars we make ninety
thousand dollars a year and somehow in
our brains figure out that our children
deserve a fifty thousand dollar Honda
SUV and now we have to take the kids out
of private school because we can't pay
the payments on the SUV and the private
school because we didn't do math we're
21 years old we buy a $10,000 car run up
ten thousand dollars in credit card debt
and have ten thousand dollars in medical
bills and make thirty thousand dollars a
year when you make thirty thousand
dollars a year
there's nowhere in that plan that thirty
thousand the ten thousand dollar car
makes sense there's nowhere in that plan
that running up a bunch of credit card
debt gives you any room to breathe you
already can't breathe we have three kids
we make twenty-eight thousand dollars a
year should I go back to work the woman
asks twenty eight thousand dollar income
with three kids our health care is
provided by Medicaid which is welfare
because we qualify if I go back to work
we won't qualify for that and if we go
back to work if I go back to work the I
have to pay for daycare and I'm not sure
I'm gonna even break even at least she
was doing math up front and thinking of
before she made the decision and of
course her answer to our equation is
both she and her husband need to develop
some kind of a long-term career path and
a short-term series of part-time jobs
and extra jobs and small business ideas
that create an income that at least
doubles the bad news is they only make
$28,000 a year the good news is with a
little bit of work in ingenuity they
easily can double their household income
and then they don't worry about being on
the government Dole and you got a long
term game plan to get yourself out it's
not a matter of simply her going back to
work that's a limited view of that
situation I actually didn't answer her
question properly when she called what
does all of this have in common
every single one of these things have in
common adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good Stephen
Covey in the book the 7 Habits of Highly
Effective People says number one habit
of Highly Effective People is their
proactive they happen two things one of
the other habits is you begin with the
end in mind
so when broke people say I can afford
this you know what they're saying I
think I might be able to pay the
payments that's what broke people mean
when they say that if you don't want to
be broke people anymore you get out of
the land of payments if you don't want
to be broke people anymore you sit down
and you say hey here's what we make
here's the size of our mess what are we
going to do to increase our income and
decrease our out go to be able to
address the mess faster it really is
sixth grade or fourth grade math it
really and truly is but you have to get
in front of it instead of running behind
it all the time getting in front of it
is you look at your situation before you
make a decision not after you've made
the decision a 44 thousand dollar SUV
when you make $85,000 a year is stupid
whether you paid cash for it or not it's
still stupid but when you finance that
it's double triple stupid but it felt
good when you bought it and Mama's gonna
be pissed at Dave Ramsey because her
husband called the show and he said
you're stupid and mama loves that car
I'll just tell you
how many times does that story been
repeated in the last 25 years I'm a cuss
word and some of your all's houses
that's fine I'm everybody's got to have
a gift I've got it I'm okay but we have
to begin with the end in mind it's
called being a grown-up you have to look
at the situation and go there's no
possible way a sane individual is going
to make that decision but the thing is
that we're not saying when we're making
half the decisions because we're
operating on about a four-year-old level
meaning we impulse our butts off I'm
tired and it's good to eat he's got to
eat we got to go out to eat cuz I'm
tired I work hard I'll call the
wambulance we all work hard I'm sorry if
you'd have followed me around the last
six days you'd be in the hospital some
of you we all work hard when we you poor
little thing because let me tell you
what that going out to eat looks like it
looks like you're 26 years old you make
thirty thousand bucks a year you're 21
years old you make thirty thousand bucks
a year and you're up ten thousand
dollars in credit card debt because you
bebop in and out of restaurants you
bebop into a vacation you can't afford
you bebop your butt down to the pet
store and buy something you can't afford
you bebop through target some of you go
to Walmart for entertainment give me a
break
you might be a redneck if Walmart is
your entertainment and no wonder you run
up debt no wonder you can't breathe no
wonder because you've got you got
payments coming out your dadgum
ears man and nobody goes in debt ten
listen people that make $30,000 a year
they're 21 years old they don't go
$10,000 in debt in one purchase they
don't run they don't use their credit
card and buy one thing for $10,000 no
it's $1,050 things its death by a
thousand cuts and then you look up and
go oh my god what have we done what have
we done how stupid are we now I'm on
your team
I've done it too but I'm just telling
you a lot of stuff that's happened in
this hour on this show is stuff that is
unbelievably preventable you just look
at it and go no we're not gonna run our
dog matter of fact we're not gonna
finance our dog and we're sure it's crap
not financing a cat you know it's not
happening period period we're not we're
not buying this car honey I know you
want a nice car honey you know what
we're broke broke people don't buy
$45,000 Honda SUVs we're broke
and you know how I know we're broke
because we're gonna be money that's how
I know we're broke when we make a lot of
money yeah but it's all gone have you
not noticed we don't have any money we
don't have any money
what any money no we're not going to eat
why we're broke one of the money you're
not in freaking Congress you can't just
print it in the basement
you have to live on less than you make
and you have to have a plan and you have
to be intentional I meet people that
make $30,000 a year that save money
I mean people to make $130,000 a year
couldn't save money if they had to it
hasn't anything do with the income it's
got to do with you freaking controlling
the person in your mirror it's you
deciding I'm gonna be a grown-up
I'm gonna be an adult and that's if
you're 52 you're 22 or you're 12 adults
devise a plan and follow it children do
what feels good everybody's all worried
about it boys feelings these days I'm
not worried about your feelings I'll
make a living hurting your feelings
I don't give a crap about your feelings
I'm let me tell you what feels good not
having any dadgum payment so what feels
good having a pile of money in the bank
that feels good being wealthy enough to
be take your eyes off yourself and not
be so bad blame self-centered and
actually be generous or there's some
room some margin in your budget and you
can give money to somebody else that's
hurting that feels good
but no we live on the junk food of
Finance and and financially we've got an
obese culture let's lost its mind and so
you guys you have to be weird normal is
rokh The Wall Street Journal says 70% of
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck that's seven out of ten houses
on your street and I don't care what
street you live on at seven out of ten
houses see all those 10 houses in your
mind seven of those people are broke oh
they look good but they're acting rich
they're not rich it's what they call in
Texas big hat no cattle don't live like
that it's time to be weird those of you
that want a weird beat that 101 with
money you got to do weird things because
normal is broke and if you do normal
stuff you're gonna have normal results
it's time to stop it this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]